[Music]
you know I didn't go to space but I can
pretend like I'm in space how's
this that's about all I got that's about
all I got it was unfortunate but I tried
I tried now I we're going to learn a
little bit about what it takes to live
have fun and do work in space I have in
my pocket and I always carry one because
I am a space correspondent this is a
space pen has anybody ever heard of
these raise your hand if you've heard of
a space pen do you know how it works I
mean because the trick is when you're in
space and you go to WR you don't have
the advantage of having gravity to help
the ink flow so they actually spent
quite a bit of money spent a lot of time
and Technology to create a pen that has
a little bit of gas in there that sends
the ink down and allows you to write in
space that that's how the US solved the
problem do you know how the Russians
solved that same problem number two
pencil yes
so there's more than one way to skin a
cat in space all right so we're going to
learn about a lot of things like that
for example these suits you see these
big fat suits Michelin Man kind of
things it's kind of hard to do work in
space as a matter of fact when you talk
to space Walkers who spend upwards of
six sometimes even longer hours in these
suits eight hours they come back and
their hands are bloody literally because
they have to keep squeezing it's it's
constant pressure on those gloves and
there's constantly as they do their work
having to fight against the suit we're
going to talk uh see in just a little
bit a novel new idea for a space suit
which would change the whole equation in
a very very big way now there were some
pictures up here of some people in space
washing their hair and fuing around in
space we're going to talk to them uh and
and get a little sense from them as to
how they go about life in space uh it's
obviously very different when you take
gravity out of the equation we're also
um going to hear from somebody directly
from space Tracy Caldwell Dyson who's up
on the International Space Station she
launched in April uh how many people
know here how many people are in space
at the moment do you know there's six
people on the International Space
Station six people up there and and
that's a very exciting thing you know
the space station is about the size of a
football field now it's about a million
pounds of course doesn't weigh anything
in space it's a million pounds of mass
and with the six people on there they
can do an awful lot of scientific
experiments and there's we're just
beginning that era for the space station
the construction phase is now winding
down the shuttle is winding down and now
we're moving to a very exciting era for
the space station where who knows what
we'll discover up there uh that we can
only find because we take gravity out of
the equation and learn a little
something about how protein crystals
grow how drugs can be made uh how how uh
bacterium uh operate and and become more
virulent there's a lot of interesting
science that we're just on the cusp of
at the International Space Station now
uh Tracy cwell Dyson she is a very
interesting person uh and she um has
some very interesting things to say
about what it's like to live in space
and we are we didn't just get anybody to
ask the questions there were over a
hundred students who submitted questions
suggested questions to send up to her
for her to answer there are the six
finalists are sitting in sitting in the
front row I want them to stand up please
stand
up they are Muhammad Sabor Emily Dean
shazen Khan Johnny mcnicholas kzzie
Chang and Natalie puos give them a round
of applause they ask some really good
questions
and so they're they're going to be like
your little proxy today uh and uh on
your behalf they have asked questions of
her you guys can sit down for now and uh
they haven't even heard the answers yet
we didn't even do it in rehearsal so
this is they're on the edge of their
seats so the longer I talk the more
nervous they're going to get now so I I
better I better move along here let's
tell tell you a little bit about Tracy's
trip to space she launched in April on a
soyou rocket and we have a little video
to show you how she got to where she is
teams in Houston are ready to to support
you we're all ready to to do our work
and and I'm sure you are also
ready sa fight
Tracy
[Music]
two liftoff liftoff as Alexander spov
Tracy cwell Dyson and mik Coro beginning
their Journey to the International Space
Station the soyes is heading toward a
linkup with the International Space
Station the station Commander being
instructed by the Russian flight control
team now to open up the equalization
vals and hatches is now
[Music]
open hi py it's Mom you all look
wonderful and you look like you had a
good
flight and happy
Easter hello Tracy it's your husband
you're grin from here to here it looks
like you're happy to be in your
home enjoy your time up there and I'll
be talking to you soon I love you
love you to
you all right ladies and gentlemen
without much further Ado let's go almost
live to space just a few days ago and
listen to Tracy cwal Dyson as she
answers your questions here she is hello
to all of you at the world Science
Festival in New York City I'm Tracy
Caldwell Dyson welcoming you to the
International Space Station right now
we're orbiting 220 Mi above the Earth
traveling at a speed of 177,000 500 mph
I'm originally from California and I
love music in fact I'm the lead singer
for an all astronaut band called Max Q
back home on Earth I became an astronaut
in 1998 the same year as my fellow
astronaut Leland Melvin who's with you
today hi leelan I hope you're doing well
life in space is very different than
life on Earth and it's a lot of fun
being weightlessness as you can
tell
I'm really excited to be able to answer
a few of your questions from the
students who are there in the audience
today so let's get to those questions
now first from Moab Sabor a 12th grader
at Manhattan Center for Science in
mathematics and he asks what is your
role on ISS and what is a typical day
for you at work well Muhammad I'm a
flight engineer and my job is to help
maintain this amazing space station that
we have I perform experiments for the
scientists on the ground and I help to
operate robotic arms and do space walks
in order to help build and also repair
the space station if needed here's a
question from Emily Dean a sixth grader
at the Brooklyn Prospect charter school
and Emily asks when you sleep do you
just float or do you strap yourself to a
bed and if you have a blanket how does
it stay on well Emily I do float I but I
float inside of a sleeping bag and my
sleeping bag is strapped though lightly
to the wall of my crew quarter and my
crew quarter is about the size of a big
big box that you could probably fit a
refrigerator in and I don't use a
blanket cuz my sleeping bag keeps me
pretty
warm okay this one's from shazen Khan an
11th grader at Queens High School for
the Sciences at New York College and she
asks human space flight is very
expensive expensive and timec consuming
wouldn't it be better to fund and send
more robotic spacecraft to explore outer
space what's your justification for
human missions well shazen that's a
really hard question but a very good one
I'll tell you that life itself is very
timec consuming and expensive and
exploration is a an important part about
human history our human history and so
if you believe that then consider that
there's no replacement for human senses
uh in Exploration senses like your sight
your hearing your taste your touch your
sense of smell and most important
probably is your sense of intuition now
it's um I believe that if you uh
consider that like learning music for
instance would it be better to learn
music
from uh from say a radio or actually
going to a concert itself and so I
believe that you need both robotic
missions and human missions and in order
to improve human life here on Earth then
there's no other way to do that but
through human missions where we bring
back the technology that's developed to
help execute those missions I really
appreciate your question because it
really does explain why we're here next
we have Johnny mcnicholas a first grader
at Goose Hill Primary School in Cold
Spring Harbor New
York I like this one Johnny asks do you
feel like a superhero in space and what
kind of music do you listen to on the
space station well well Johnny I do feel
like a superhero I get to zoom around in
this huge space station although I don't
have a cape but Superman I mean
Spider-Man doesn't either and neither
does Woman Wonder Woman but you do kind
of feel like you're Larger than Life as
you look out the window and see the
earth below and I do listen to music
here on Space Station most of it is
Christian rock next we have kzzie Chang
and 11th grader at the Bronx School of
Science and kzzie asks does being in
space give you a completely new outlook
on the universe and how significant or
insignificant we are I would say that
definitely the view of Earth it is a
completely new look at the universe
especially when you see the stars and
the blackest black you've ever seen in
the background and are we significant
well when you look out at that black sky
that we call the universe then and you
see this blue planet below you then you
think there must be some significance
but are we insignificant well when you
look into the black Ness of space and
you think that goes on for Infinity you
wonder just how significant you could be
it's a really good question and I think
that you could argue
both and last but not least we have
Natalya puos a fourth grader at ps58 the
Carol school in
Brooklyn Natalia asks what do astronauts
take to eat do you have to be careful
what you eat in space do you eat fresh
fruit or is it all packaged food well
Natalia astronauts take um very little
with them to eat because it's all packed
for them and brought up in in other
vehicles such as the shuttle or a
progress we uh do have foods that are
brought up foods like chocolate covered
coffee
beans
strawberries and one of my favorites
coffee with cream and sugar you do have
to be really careful with how you eat
and what you eat because things float
just like you do and they float
everywhere as you can see so they do
bring us fresh fruit and um on the
shuttle and on progresses because uh as
you know it could spoil and so we can't
keep it here for long and uh a lot of it
most of it is packaged food well anyway
thanks for all your excellent questions
it's been fun sharing this experience
with you and I hope you're having a
great time at the world Science Festival
be well and add
Austra all
right
pretty cool stuff so I imagine you have
a few more great questions guys give
them a round of applause those really
good
questions but I I'm willing to guess
there are a few more questions that you
all have and of course you does
everybody know what the number one
question that is asked of astronauts
is how do you go to the bathroom right
so and in a word it sucks but we'll
explain in just a moment and and we're
going to have some people who have been
there to do that so let's uh let's take
a look at who's coming up on stage here
and give you a little sense of who
you're about to meet okay the astronauts
are kind of young aren't they these days
no this is Sandy Magnus at a younger age
and she uh she grew up in Belleville
Illinois and she um really enjoyed
playing soccer I believe Sandy is that
you right up there is that that the
right place is that you okay that's
Sandy there playing soccer she still
plays soccer you still play soccer I
don't know if you did it on the space
station though
and uh ultimately she studied hard and
became an engineer uh and she got to do
cool things like this to get ready to go
to space which is um uh you know
actually that it's just as much fun to
train for a space mission I think as it
is to go to space and these guys will
tell you about a little bit about that
and uh and then there's the the classic
astronaut portrait that's Sandy she's
coming up here in a second joining her
is the only astronaut in the astronaut
Corp who played professional football
I'll be it for about 30 seconds I think
right it was well this is this is Young
Leeland there he is when he played for
the Detroit Lions before he pulled his
hamstring and uh that actually that I
we've talked to lean about this before
that injury was probably a good thing
for him because it sent him on a
completely different direction and um
there it is that's where he's said sort
of uh mad science kind of guy and uh
Leland is uh yeah well you know it's
he's he's a good guy everybody loves
Leland and uh he's been to space a
couple of times and um has a great
interesting eclectic career but it's a
great lesson for all you kids out there
listen sports are wonderful Sandy played
soccer Leland played football at a very
high level don't forget about the books
you got to keep studying it's just if
nothing else it's a good fallback when
the hamstring goes or when you just
can't do the sports anymore so in any
case they're going to come up here and
te and do a bunch of things they have a
whole presentation about life and space
and then after that we're going to be
able to take some of your questions so
if you have any questions keep them in
mind uh at the I'll come out in the
audience with a microphone and we'll get
your questions out out addressed to them
so without further Ado let me introduce
Sandy Magnus and Leland
Melvin good
job hello
everyone hello do
all
right how many of you out here Play
Sports football basketball soccer tennis
what
else running
swimming baseball okay well Sports was
very important in my life as miles just
mentioned but you know the training for
sports is very similar to the training
that we do for being an astronaut and I
want to tell you a little bit about how
my how I became an astronaut I I grew up
in Lynchburg Virginia small town and uh
my uh my dad taught me all about sports
but he made sure because they were both
School teachers they made sure that I
had a a strong foundation in the
academic so if you want to be a ball
player you can always go for that a
rapper musician whatever go for it but
make sure you have that education to
fall back on his Milad because if you
pull your hamstring you still have an
opportunity to be an astronaut I flew on
two space shuttle
missions I flew on two space shuttle
missions STS 122 and STS 129 and I did
what we call a short duration space
flight and s's going to talk a little
bit about her doing a long duration
space flight I flew I well I I was a a
soccer player as well but so Leland
asked how many of you guys play sports
so how many of you guys like
science everybody should be raising
their hands um that's why I got into
being astronaut because I like the whole
idea of of uh learning about how the
world works and then exploring it it's
really a lot of fun and since I've
joined NASA I've had the opportunity to
to fly twice as well my first mission
was a short Mission just like uh
Leland's where you take the shuttle to
the station deliver some things attach
it come home but on my second mission
which I just returned from last uh March
I was able to live on the space station
for four and a half months uh similar to
what you see Tracy doing now and that's
really a great adventure it's such a
difference between a short Mission and a
long Mission because when you're on a
short Mission you're very much in a
Sprint mode you're you're hurrying
you're hurrying you've got things to do
you've got a short amount of time to get
it done in you really can't afford to
step back and think about what's going
on but living there for four and a half
months I had Sunday you know half a
Saturday and Sunday is off and I
developed a lifestyle there I mean that
was my life that was my home and it was
really really special to get to
experience that and we're going to talk
a little bit more about that today but
of course before we uh we uh get to live
on the space station we have to actually
get there and Leland will explain a
little bit about that thanks Andy so we
trained for about a year and a half or
about a year for a space shuttle flight
and I my first flight we trained uh I
did Robotics and I'll show you some of
the some of the things we've done later
but you first have got to get in the
suit and get ready to get on the vehicle
so can you roll the video please so we
we're about three and a half hours
before we launch we're in our pumpkin
suits they put us in we walk out we get
in the vehicle this is the Gantry to get
us into the shuttle until we get in kind
of sit there and we wait for that
proverbial 321 blast off actually lift
off because Blast Off doesn't sound too
cool when you're on a rocket with a lot
of propellant
but we have a liftoff and it was one of
the most amazing things I've ever felt
you know you're shaking you're rattling
you're rolling and people ask me if I
was afraid and I said no because I was
the one screaming
woohoo so we do a rotation we're going
up we uh about two and a half minutes
into the flight the solid rocket
boosters jettison and so those fall back
in the ocean and uh we have a tugbo that
actually picks them up when we we reuse
them and then about 8 and 1/2 minutes
later you are now in space and the
external tank is jettisoned so that's
falling back to the Earth burning up
some pieces fall in the ocean and then
you're trying to turn this vehicle from
your spaceship into your home so that's
me coming out of my my pumpkin suit
there's Bobby playing with his water bag
and there's no attitude in space snow up
or down so there's comrade right side up
and I'm kind of upside down scorches
working in the front so that's kind of
uh the the first part of getting to
space now we're going to talk about what
we actually do working in space you know
you train all this time we did robotics
space walks uh payloads and science all
these different types of things so we
want to show you some of the other
things that we do in space can roll the
video so anyone here play video
games okay right everyone does but um I
never really played a lot of video games
but all of our training to do the
robotics is like a big video game when I
went to space we didn't have this window
that could look out so we had to do
everything with the the monitors there
that you see so that's the robotics
workstation on the station we have a
shuttle arm and we have a station arm so
what we do is we grab the payloads out
of the payload Bay of the shuttle
present them to the station arm that's
what's going on here this is one of our
pallets that we took up on SCS 1222
about 30,000 pounds of cargo that we put
up on the space station so that goes up
and then we grapple it with the station
arm and then put it in place on the
space station so that's a way that we
actually can service the space station
when the space shuttle goes away will
have all of that Hardware up there like
control moment
pumps spare parts for the uh for the
robotic arm those things are there
prepositioned ready to uh be used so
that's uh working in space next
slide so after you work in space you do
all these things you've got to come home
so this is a fly around kind of sped up
a little bit but a fly around of the
space station as the shuttle goes around
it so we want to take pictures of it
make video of it to make sure that
there's no damage on the station so we
actually send these pictures back down
to the ground they can kind of assess
the station now the station is about as
long as the football field and you have
all these different modules put together
with from uh people from all over the
world it's a great international program
and when I was up there we had so many
people working hard together I had to
learn some Russian Sandy spent a lot of
time in Russia working Japan Germany all
over the world to get this International
Space Station done so that's another
part of working space coming home next
slide
and from this vantage point you see so
many beautiful colors when you look out
the window you sometimes see the the
Earth limb is where the sun is rising we
don't have that picture here but the
Caribbean the colors of the water are so
beautiful aqua teal blue all these
colors you almost need new definitions
to Define what the colors are because
they're just so strikingly rich and it's
just one of the most beautiful things
when you see out the window the planet
going by you you're going by every 90
minutes around the planet
and so you see so you know snow cab
mountains the oceans the uh I was
looking down at my friend's house with a
zoom lens to see what he was doing but
you can see so many really cool things
and uh it's just an amazing amazing site
yeah it's funny people have asked me uh
when I've given different talks if I
ever have gotten if I ever got bored
while I was on the space station it's
like no you you can't get bored because
you can just simply when you have a free
moment go look out the window and see
what part of the earth is wondering by
cuz even if over the ocean and we do
have so much ocean and we really are a
water Planet the cloud formations all
have different characteristics and all
moods and things like this so it's uh
it's always very interesting to look out
the window so you're never bored we stay
busy as Leland mentioned we do the
Robotics and space walks to support the
construction and maintenance of the
station and we have a lot of Earth
photography we do for the earth
scientists but there's a lot of other
science that we do in space as well and
it really is an international effort one
day I was talking to scientists from the
US Germany Japan and Russia and it was
really kind of neat um in the we're in
the microgravity environment if you can
throw the tape there's a really uh nice
visual of why we do studies in space
this is water it's a reptile I am a
reptile this is true on the ground of
course gravity drives the behavior of
liquids especially you know you pour it
into a glass it stays in the glass it
takes the shape of the glass because
that's gravity gravity working on the
water in space for liquid something
called surface tension takes over and
that drives the behavior and so here you
see a very strong example of what
surface tension forces do when they're
interacting with your hand or with other
surface it kind of gives water a sticky
or liquids a sticky feel if you will and
so we're there in space doing these
experiments on you know various
phenomenon just to understand what
changes because as we learn how
materials grow differently how liquids
behave differently how our bodies change
in space we can take all of that
knowledge and not only apply it to make
technology we need to continue
exploration but we can take that
technology
uh and bring it back into everyday lives
you know your UV coating on your
sunglasses some of you guys are into
golf or bicycling you've got really
strong lightweight Metals all these
things come out of the space program so
this is why we're on the space station
so we do a lot of work up there but and
of course when we're there for four and
a half months we have to figure out how
to live in space too which is which is
sort of fun and challenging and Leland
can talk to you a little bit about that
okay so Tracy talked about her sleeping
her crew quarters on the space station
now when you're a short duration space
flight member you don't have the luxury
of having your own crew quarters so you
have to figure out where you're going to
put your sleeping bag how you're going
to oriented and how you're going to
sleep so we've got a little video
showing me sleeping on the space
station and actually this is a good a
good sample of the background noise
there's kind of a general high level of
white noise on the station yeah I wore
earplugs actually while I was
sleeping yeah me too inside my crew
quarters inside your crew quarters how
you doing
oh it's time to wake up this is our
sleeping bag right here sleeping in node
one and uh had a good night's sleep but
now it's time to get to
work all
right time to go so so if you're
sleeping in space and you're used to
having a pillow on the ground how do you
put a pillow on your head in space and
that was a concern I had how am I going
to you know how I'm going to have this
pillow around my head and I said oh yeah
velcro you just velcro the pillow to
your head
and it's all in place ready to go so you
for the short duration flights you know
we put these sleeping bags anywhere you
kind of Bungee them anywhere you want so
when you undock from the space station
you have we had six people actually six
people on my second flight but seven
people on my first flight that were
actually having to maneuver around this
small area so you had you know sleeping
bags going this way some people crossing
and I slept actually in the airlock with
Mike foreman and Mike he's a pretty big
guy you know we're sitting there trying
to you know Orient our sleeping bags so
he actually had his his feet of his
sleeping bag oriented right where my
head was so every time I woke up in the
middle of the night I'm like pushing on
his feet you know trying to get to the
bathroom and so forth but you want to
try to make sure you have your sleeping
bags oriented the right way so that's
sleeping in space how do you do personal
hygiene space you know one of the things
that you have to do is make sure you're
stay clean and so next slide this is how
we uh brush our teeth and space just
like you would on the ground you know
toothpaste toothbrush you see here's my
little personal hygiene kit I've got
some uh some deodorant got my little
Clippers there on the bottom you know
I've got some lotion all these different
things you have you know on the ground
the key here is it when you go to spit
Your you know your toothpaste and your
Slava out you can't just go spit it out
in the sink there's no sink so what we
have to do is get a washcloth this is
what we did they have a different way of
processing
their stuff we can get a washcloth and
we just you know very
slowly spit into the washcloth close it
up and get it to wet the washcloth and
then we put that in a little grommet let
it sit there for maybe a few hours let
it dry out and we put that in our dry
trash now how do you take care of your
okay so short timers they need
pillows they can't swallow their
toothpaste like we do in the long
duration that's nasty no it's fine just
you just dilute it with a little bit of
water and then it's just like a fresh
minty flavor and it's okay minty flavor
you you know we have we have a
consumable issue when you're up there
it's like being on a camping trip right
you only have so many wash Rags you only
have so many towels you only have so
many clothes and so you get into these
modes of how to conserve things as much
as possible and by swallowing your
toothpaste you're saving a lot of wash
EGS over time and it just gets really
messy over months and months of doing
that so it's not so good okay well
that's all I know so so the next next
thing of living in space is you know
that million-dollar question how do you
use the bathroom in space and Miles said
it
sucks and it's very delicate thing to do
you don't want to rush when you're using
the bathroom on my first flight um you
know you kind of sit down I'll show you
we have a different toilet than we do
from the station okay our our toilet
looks more like a a real toilet they've
got something that looks like something
from the stone ages but when you train
to use the toilet on the ground they
actually have a video camera in the
bottom of the toilet so because you know
you've got to be lined up just right or
you're going to be cleaning lots of
things that you don't want to be
cleaning so so you know if you can hit
the
crosshairs you have a little monitor
sitting right in front of you you want
to make sure you hit the crosshairs so I
mean but this is all living in space
it's very important you got to got to be
perfect at it you know so you don't want
things you know floating around so so
the toilet on the shuttle side is
conventional we have things that hold
our legs down we have stirups and so
forth but on the other hand sy's toilet
next
slide we had a this is a Russian uh
design it's very simple but it's
actually easy to use you do worry the
first time you use the restroom how well
is it going to work because that's not
really as a rookie how you want to start
your mission
um no you don't want it works really
simply it's a really simple concept I
mean when the engineers had to figure
out how to make toilets the whole idea
was make things go away from you so they
came up with air flow as a good
substitute for gravity and so you turn
on a switch it starts some air flow
through the funnel and through the hose
and you can urinate right into the
funnel and uh the urine gets captured
into some tanks and on board now we have
the ability to recycle urine and recycle
condensator bad water and make it
potable so we're closing our life
support system so it's all
self-contained which is what we need to
do to continue our exploration away from
the earth and so um it works pretty well
we have a toilet seat that we sit on and
you know on the shuttle Leland mentioned
there's some some uh straps that can
hold you down this is a small enough
compartment that I could put one hand on
the ceiling and hold myself onto the uh
onto the toilet it it works fine it's
simple which is good if the toilet
breaks down it stops all work on the
space station because everybody on the
ground is now focused on getting the
toilet running again so you need a
toilet that's highly reliable but um of
course also living in space you know we
have to figure out how to eat for space
station we are on a 16-day standard
rotating menu and uh so it means every
16 days we see the same food and it's
not bad we don't have a refrigerator the
food's either uh dehydrated we add water
or it's sort of like meals ready to eat
where you've got cans and and pouches
that you warm up there's food from
Russia there's food from the US it's
quite varied and then with J Japan has
shown up with some food I think Europe
is working on some so we do have some
variety even though every 16 days it's
the same thing if you show the uh the
food video we were going to be up there
over a lot of holidays and I like to
cook so I actually did some cooking in
space this is the galley area we have
two of these now on Space Station this
is back in the Russian segment it was
very comfortable to go to the ceiling
and then put your drink bag there at the
galley I'm actually extracting water
into a drink bag um like I said I like
to cook so I planned on doing some
cooking which in space means you're
mixing things together in different new
exciting ways uh we were up there for
Christmas and Russian Christmas and New
Year's we had a lot of holidays and so I
had some time and I basically discovered
that with duck bag uh duct tape and
Ziploc bags you can pretty much do
anything what is that well let's see I
think that might be my tuna surprise and
I had an Italian night and it was
actually turned out pretty good it was
not so appetizing but it was new flavor
so we enjoyed
it so you have to be careful when eating
space of course um Leland mentioned
hygiene if you'll show the next video as
a female one of the more challenging
things that I had to figure out how to
do which surprised me was how to wash my
hair because I can't just get under a
shower and let you know water falling on
your head is a beautiful thing everyone
don't take that for granted um I didn't
have that problem yeah he's got the
perfect space haircut mine's mine and
Tracy is not so good but I had to figure
out how to get the water on my hair out
of the drink bag without splashing it
all over and get the shampoo on and then
vigorously rub the shampoo and again
without splashing bubbles all over the
place and of course we're trying to
minimize towel so I can't use three
towels every time I'm trying to wash my
hair and that took about a month to
figure out and F and finally uh we do
have chores in space if you show the
next video you show we have to vacuum
every week we have to dust it's a little
bit more fun up there to do chores than
here you can float around holding the
VMA soccer player so I was holding the
vacuum cleaner on my foot and um so you
know we do have time to have fun and
space and I think Leland you can talk
some more about that yeah so fun in
space you know we have different things
that we do we call them stupid astronaut
tricks and uh you know being a former
football player you know for like you
know what Miles said you know 30 seconds
in the NFL maybe 15 seconds in the NFL I
had a relationship with the NFL Hall of
Fame and so we were actually able to
take up the NFL Super Bowl coin on our
SCS 122 mission in November and I was
able to flip that in space and that came
back down and they used it in the coin
TOS with emit Smith so I'm going to show
you a little video clip of how you flip
a coin in
space we're on the International Space
Station with Commander Williams and
Commander hobah Commander Williams is
representing the AFC Army and Commander
hobah is representing the Navy the NFC
we're going to do a coin toss here here
are both sides of the coin this is Heads
This is
Tails the coin's gone how are we going
to get side all right let's
go so so before we actually float up to
get the coin we had to do you know rocks
papers and scissors to decide who what
Commander you know those you know
military guys are so
competitive oh that was the football you
got to watch out for tackling his
face now this doesn't hurt at all it it
feels just wonderful um one more slow
motion
[Music]
move now actually real quick if you talk
about physics and space this is a
perfect example of Newton's laws and
action cuz they're going to be flying
into that next module until they hit a
wall or somebody stops them because it's
energy in the system that's going to
keep in motion you could apply physics
to fotball in space very easily so what
we had to do was have someone in the
Columbus module the other module
actually catch us as we went down
because the last thing I wanted was
another cut on my head from that first
coin toss thing so next uh let me see so
we have some more stupid astronut we
have some more stupid astronauts we run
the next slide on some more stupid
astronaut when I was younger I could oh
these are yours oh this is mine okay
playing with your food in space very
important when you take water out of
your drink bad it assumes a sphere and
so you know when the water starts
floating away you can actually put the
straw in it and move it around so you
can guide it around the station and this
is three M&M's you know we're again
stupid astronaut tricks playing with
your
food so here's the final assault on the
water bubble now don't do this at home
okay it's a requirement to play with
your food
you
know almost choked go ahead Sandy I'm a
frustrated gymnast I never learned to do
a cartwheel here on the planet and so
while I was up there I did a lot of just
fun stuff you can act out your favorite
superhero roles you can do all kinds of
fun things in your off time when you're
on orbit so we also have to exercise in
space right that's true um you know we
have a lot of fun on the weekends but an
exercise is something we like to do for
fun stress relief and we do two hours of
exercise a day in order to keep our
bones and our muscles strong enough to
come back uh when we're returning and if
you can go ahead and roll the video we
have several examples of of exercise
this is the very early resistive
exercise device it's simulating
weightlifting we're working against some
some bungees to do squats and some of
these big muscle group type of exercises
this is a device that Mike and I put
together this is also a resistive excise
device and this really makes you feel
like you're lifting weights and I had
that nice tired muscle feeling every day
after working out on the advanced
resistance exercise device I tended to
stretch every day too because your
natural body position is kind of like
this and people have been complaining of
calves and hamstrings tight when they
get back we do an hour of cardiovascular
exercise you can run on the treadmill
bungee yourself down that gives you a
good nice pounding Dynamic loading on
your legs and and hips and bones and and
then on the bicycle ergometer you can go
and do Sprint recovery kinds of things
and get a really good cardiovascular
workout and if you do this pretty
religiously for two hours a day you and
with these very various types of
exercises you can come back in pretty
good shape I was able to come back stand
up walk off the Orbiter I didn't lose
any bone or muscle we're slowly learning
you know that the with the right
exercise protocols and things like this
we can mitigate some of the bone and
muscle mass we loss that we've seen in
the past we do know if you lose bone
mass in space uh bone density in space
you can regrow that bone but it grows
back in a slightly different fashion the
structures differently and I mentioned
earlier how we're human guinea pigs and
we're doing science to understand how
the the human body changes in space and
we're looking at this structure change
and and again trying to see if there's
some applications to osteoporosis and
and really understanding what that means
so it's really very exciting everything
we do is sort of inter interconnected in
space so some final thoughts you roll
the next slide talk about this
International Space Station that we have
it's one of the most uh incredible
vehicles for bringing people together
and on my first flight SCS 122 on the
day that we docked to the space station
the first female Commander Dr Peggy
witson invited us over to dinner in the
service module so what you see here is a
service module and she's she said okay
you guys bring the vegetables and we'll
have the meat so we brought over some
rehydrated vegetables we floated over we
all just kind of assembled around the
table there was some music playing sh
was playing Smooth Operator you know
we're all kind of you know kind of
grooving in there eating and you thought
about this the diversity of This Crew it
was uh African-American Asian-American
uh French German Russian just the whole
gamut of of people and the most
incredible thing was we're all here
breaking bread around this table going
17,500 mil hour every 90 minutes
circling the globe and so we were
thinking that as you look out the window
down below who's eating and breaking
bread together what different races
cultures Creeds are working together for
civilization for the betterment of
humankind and I think if more people can
come to the space station and work
together in this International crew
there'll be no more Wars there'll be no
more racism there'll be no more issues
so all of you get
ready for space so that we can bring
this bring this Collective together and
it's just so important that we do this
and so that's that was a thought that I
had you know my first flight and the
second flight was very International
sy's been on some very international
flights and people have worked together
just like that yeah really the space
station when you think about it is a
testimony to what human beings can do
and we put our minds to it you we had to
work across for decades we had to work
about different languages different
cultures different ways of approaching
engineering problems different ways of
handling problems different measurement
systems um all these things to build the
space station and we did it we we slowly
put it up piece by piece it went
together perfectly the first time on
orbit when we put these pieces from all
over the world together uh working out
the planning of the missions in
international forums we ran into
problems you know we ran into situations
where we had disagreements we were able
to work work through it all and I had a
moment where I was on Space Station one
day after I talked to every single
control center about something or other
it's like wow I mean look at this we did
this it took a lot of Blood Sweat and
Tears a lot of dedication a lot of
effort a lot of determination but we did
it and it's really a spectacular thing
and it's intangible benefit I think
we're going to get from the space
station program that we'll see in the
next few decades is it's a model for how
we can all work together it's just
spectacular it is and one of the things
that we haven't shown you yet is how to
do space walking and I we have these two
suits here Dave anuma is going to come
up in a minute and talk about some
future Next Generation suits but I'm
going to roll the clip showing how
Robotics and the space walks work
together so this is Bobby satra getting
into a suit in the airlock so Nicole cam
Nicole STD is helping him there's Mike
Foreman he's one of my crew mates and
they're coming out of the airlock to do
a servicing of an antenna we're going to
take an antenna out of the payload Bay
and attach it to the station so I was
working the robotic arm flying Bobby
around Bob Bob was actually uh you know
flying in to get the antenna there he is
going into the getting ready to go into
the P Bay there's Mike with a go Navy
beat Army so you know what flavor he is
he's Navy guy here's the antenna here in
the payload Bay and we actually took
that up and installed it on the uh up on
the space station so that that's kind of
the interaction we have with space
walking and Robotics to get things done
get things positioned on the space
station Sandy and of course for space
walks are pretty much the most
physically demanding thing that we do
both in training and and on orbit and so
another reason that we exercise is so
we're fit enough whenever we're called
upon to go fix something outside and get
in the suits they're very bulky um they
weigh a few hundred pounds you the
joints kind of fit you how they fit you
they're sized for just a few different
sizes and they have some small
adjustments that can be made uh it's
actually quite spectacular I haven't
done a space walk myself but it's pretty
fun to train for it and everybody who's
been out on a spacewalk says the view is
just spectacular because you got your
peripheral vision as well but is it's
pretty demanding as we move on in into
uh surface type situations whether it's
a NE Earth asteroid object or whether
it's the moon or Mars you know we need
to become a little bit more adaptable
with our suits and I think you'll hear a
lot about that next so Leland and I I
think we'll wrap up uh we have time for
questions later miles will we'll
moderate that and uh maybe miles you can
come up and introduce our next speaker
all right all right thanks everyone
don't go too far away okay don't go too
far away so right uh lot of kids here
who among the young people here would
like to go to Mars someday raise your
hand pretty good assortment you know
it's well you you you're too old sorry
pal anyway one-way trip for you maybe
yeah I would do the one-way trip myself
and my my wife would support that
probably so um all right so you saw
these suits right and and you can
imagine these suits think of these suits
as the world's smallest spacecraft okay
they're
there's there it's filled with um oxygen
and it's inflated to a certain level and
the gloves are inflated and every time
they move their hands it takes a lot of
force and you can imagine I was talking
to John grunsfeld who uh went to the hub
the Hubble Space Telescope three times
on repair missions and he's from Chicago
he said it's like working on your car
trying to change the spark plugs 20
below zero with your ski gloves on so
it's not easy to work in space and so
scientists and engineers years have been
thinking for years and years of ways to
make it simpler and our next guest has
spent a lot of time doing that I I met
her incidentally uh at a private
facility that is um eared um geared
toward U civilians who want to go to
space to fly for example with um uh Bert
rupan and um Sir Richard Branson's um uh
Virgin Galactic spacecraft uh a lot of
scientists are thinking about ways they
can go to space and conduct experiments
on these brief sub orbital Hops and so
she's she's getting ready to go to space
herself but she's also coming up with
new and exciting ways uh that people
human beings can go to space and work
more effectively be more Nimble and
explore in a more meaningful way and in
her spare time she sails uh and as a
matter of fact has actually sailed all
the way around the world so she's a true
Adventurer an engineer and somebody
who's really thinking out of the box on
how human beings will explore in space
in the future that is to say your
generation please welcome David
Newman good
job hello
everyone afternoon it's great to be here
I'm so glad to be here it's wonderful to
hear Sandy and Leland talk I liked
Sports and music as well I was actually
a ski racer basketball player played
basketball at Notre Dame and I thought
what am I going to do for a career well
I love to design and build things I
didn't know what engineering was but it
was for me so I became an aerospace
engineer and now I have the privilege to
be a professor at MIT so what I'd like
to do is share a little bit of our
research and some of the educational
things we think about we we think about
trying to keep these astronauts healthy
and well and as you heard to perform as
best they can in in space suits now
these these mockup suits that you see in
front of you this is NASA's mark iiii it
has some Mobility it has some soft parts
and some hard parts that you see here
we're really working on the design for
the shoulder joints give a lot more
Mobility what you see over here to your
left that's a replica of the current
suit we call the extra vehicular
Mobility unit it's about 140 kilos close
to 300 lb fully charged now it's great
for space station and shuttle because
it's weightless really this is the
world's smallest spacecraft kudos to the
designers you have all of your oxygen in
there it scrubs your carbon dioxide it's
really fantastic but I'm thinking a
little bit further out
the asteroids Moon Mars how can we have
an astronaut go there work be flexible
and get all their tasks done without
wasting a lot of energy to overcome the
suit so if you can roll the first video
all space suits don't have to look like
this we don't have to look like the
Michelin Man I love this this is back in
1969 from John Hopkins Applied Physics
lab maybe a spacit should look like
this I don't know maybe we should call
it kind of the the hamster in the cage
but for you kids I want you you're
you're going to design the next space
suit you need to you're going to be the
Martian astronauts you guys are the ones
who are going to walk on Mars so we have
to think about how to come up with a
revolutionary
system what you see here is a subject
and those are Apollo arms and legs so
those come right from the Apollo
generation spacit so when you can be in
the hamster cage if you want it's not
moving too fast it's a little bit Tippy
but again just think of a different way
to design it so this is great in the 60s
they were thinking about every way now
this is Dr Paul web's space activity
suit have you ever seen a space suit
that was kind of shrunk wrap around an
astronaut neither had I but I really
think that Dr Webb had a great idea Back
in 1970 way before its time so with my
students in our lab at MIT the last 10
years we've been thinking about
alternative approaches to these kind of
very heavy wonderful space suits but you
know we have to get to Mars and have
Mobil
so I need someone on a treadmill going
like that now you heard Sandy talk a
little bit about exercise in space Also
as a researcher as an engineer kind of
Aerospace biomed engineering is my
specialty so we study the astronauts
I've had the privilege to fly three
experiments up in space with the
astronauts get to train them and take
data and we're trying to figure it out
now we are on long duration missions
that Sandy was there 4 and a half months
thank goodness she didn't lose any bone
but when you look at all that sometimes
they lose 30% muscle mass or 40%
strength loss in muscles that's okay
that's the good news right you've been
in a cast you can you can exercise after
you take the cast off you get your
muscle strength back it's kind of what
the astronauts do the skeletal loss were
really concerned about some crew lose 1
to 2% bone mineral density loss per
month okay how long is the Mars mission
going to
last
guesses year at least a year probably
about
four we're going to you're going to
spend my Martian astronauts as you young
folks here you're going to spend a
couple years round trip and we don't
want your muscles and Bones then you're
going to spend about 600 days on the
surface the only reason we're going to
Mars with people is to look for the
evidence of life and it was a great
question before robots and humans we all
do it together the robots are there now
we have precursor missions we're
learning so much about the moon and Mars
right now today I get data downloads on
the lunar surface every day and we have
the same from ours so when humans go
there it's just the added value you know
send them because their brains and to
make decisions was there really past
evidence of Life on Mars so the humans
the astronauts are going to be working
with the machines well it's my job to
think about that muscle skeletal bone
loss we don't want a lot of muscular
skeletal bone loss so if you can roll
the next
slide you saw Sandy exercising the
exercise device kind of like being a
power L lifter worked really well for
her we call this the ultimate
countermeasure I might spin you on a bed
on your way to Mars so this is
artificial gravity it's a 2 meter
centrifuge with my graduate students
there and how about this maybe you're
going to Pedal your way to Mars now you
need the propulsion to get there but I'm
going to have you cycling all the way
there because if you have six-month trip
to get there and a year and a half to
get home if you're pedaling and
exercising we really need you probably
exercising so you don't have that
muscular skill to loss and the latest
research is I might put some vibrational
soles in the bottom of your pedals
because that might really help bone loss
as well so that's what we think about in
in my lab and and all over universities
trying to work with NASA and keep the
astronauts really healthy and well and
the best conditions so they can go out
and do their tasks the best when they do
get back to the moon or
Mars we could roll the the next slide
another thing you might find in a
research lab is a robot right okay well
this is my robot here's Rudolph one of
my graduate students now I use a robot
as a surrogate astronaut these folks are
great and wonderful but uh why would we
use a robot see the robot there m tall
Chief is the name of my robot if you
know why we'll give you a little extra
NASA goodies so there's so it follows
Rudolph because we want it to do the
exact motions if you're in your suit or
if you're on Mars I want the robot to do
exact motions is the surrogate astronaut
is following the same kinematics or arm
angles and it's giving me high Precision
torque measurements of the joint how
hard am I working if I know how hard am
I working at the elbow how hard am I
working in the knees okay so it's
telling me how hard I'm working I want
the astronauts to use all their work to
do exploration not necessarily to
overcome the
suit okay so that leads us to uh kind of
a a special treat we have here if you
can roll the next video the suit that
we're designing is called the BIOS suit
now it might not look like your
conventional space suit here there I am
I'm in was called the Moonwalker up in
my lab I'm hung up by the rafters I'm
literally experiencing Mars loading Mars
is 38 gravity so on my feet there I only
see 38 of my body weight I can move I'm
actually loping you're going to lope on
on Mars you can run walk loping is ideal
so um if Rachel could come out Rachel
Foreman graduate student at
MIT gonna model the BIOS suit for you
here Rachel thanks for joining us so
this is our fourth version mockup a
mockup is a space that just looks and
feels like it it's not pressurizing her
all the way to a third of an atmosphere
these suits have to pressurize you to a
third of an atmosphere to keep you alive
in space this is about a tenth right now
so that she can interact with you but in
the lab in the vacuum chamber we
pressurize folks to the whole thing a
third of an atmosphere to keep you alive
it's pretty
mobile if she goes to she can March she
can bend down you can't do that in in
the current suits the gas pressurized
suits we're pressurizing her through the
materials directly applied to her skin
so gas pressurized balloon suit that you
have to work really hard against or
directly putting the pressure right
through on the skin now the helmet this
is actually an Apollo helmet to
demonstrate is going to be pretty
conventional looks looks the same
conventional she'll put that on so she
has really good Vision she can see
during the exploration the smarts the
advancements in the helmet are we're
going to put a really information we're
going to put an information system in
there that gives you the topology you
can see the mountains of Mars and the
craters on the moon so we'll have a
really Rich information system within
the helmet but it looks kind of
conventional cuz we want to run gas
through there so that she's you know
feels good you don't want to shrink
you've all seen the Blue Man Group no
we're not going to shrink wrap their
heads we don't want to shrink wrap the
astronaut's heads we want to give them a
lot of air but we do want to kind of put
a second skin this is called a second
skin design so we do want to use the
Second Skin design on them I think um
Rachel is will uh walk through you can
get a better look we can tell you
probably a little bit more about the
design of it in questions that answers
all right lights up she can um there you
go she can bend down you know she can do
push-ups and jumping jacks in
this so this is our vision then for the
astronauts of the future to have a very
mobile capability so that all of their
energy is all about exploration and the
search for life or other scientific
endeavors
thank you Rachel Rachel's in our lab at
MIT and she's her research is on looking
at astronaut performance and how to
enhance astronaut performance so
[Applause]
I so I think that we're going to wrap it
up and ask all the folks to come up here
and take some questions and answers
we're gonna have everybody come up this
uh let's uh let's do some questions now
it's kind of like Fashion Week here for
just a moment you know
you got to do you got to work on the
pirouette a little bit Rachel yeah yeah
all right so we're going to bring
everybody up here I've got the
microphone raise your hand if you have a
question for anybody on the panel and
I'm going to come to you Phil Donahue
style here oh my gosh we got tons we
only have 15 minutes so we're going to
do the best we can to get through let's
make him quick and piy go ahead young
lady you know how you do like
experiments how do you keep the stuff
down how do you keep well we have um
glove boxes that are sort of contain
contained and we can use duct tape which
is wonderful or velcro or magnets or
snaps or zippers or something like that
but we do have to worry about how to
keep stuff down okay yeah good question
is there aliens in
space that's the second most common
question right right after the bathroom
one right okay I didn't see any aliens
but uh you know you know Sandy looked
kind of like an alien with her reptilian
hand when she at the water but no we
didn't see any aliens but that doesn't
mean they're not out there
okay young lady um do you take any
animals up to space to see how they
react we have actually taken animals to
space while I was up there there were
two spiders there and they were the kind
of spiders that eat their web every
night and then do another a new web in
the morning and so we got to see how
they changed their web making and I know
I don't know if I ever saw a pattern
because some days they were nice and
neat webs and some days they were just a
mess some days are better than others
obviously we've had mice and um ants and
be bees and fish and spiders and
caterpillars and so we're slowly trying
to learn about how animals behave in
space getting the ride of their life
okay go uh how's it like to be back on
Earth after going to space like do you
feel different does the grab does the I
don't know does the Earth feel different
well when we first came home my first
flight I was I was uh you our commander
was telling us like move our head around
a little bit as we were getting the G's
back on the shuttle as we're coming in
the atmosphere and so that helped us you
know when you get out of your seat and
you're walking down that you don't just
kind of you know your vestibular system
is trying to kind of refigure out how to
make things work from you know turning
and knowing what attitude your head's in
so it took me about maybe two days or so
to really get back to normal um one of
the things that you had to do is look at
the Horizon The Horizon would help you
reug your Gyros so I didn't do that my
first flight but my second flight I did
I felt much better much faster yeah and
let me just add real quick you feel very
heavy and those of you who are patiently
waiting in the audience with your hands
up you're working very hard because
gravity is trying to pull your arm back
down and I felt like even as we were
coming through the atmosphere I was
getting pulled and pressed and just
attached to my seat and it's very
interesting I think be to be able to go
into space and come back and understand
what gravity is like that you are just
being pulled all the time just pinned to
the ground and it's it's fascinating so
Sandy after your long flight how long
before you felt like normal well it took
me it took me two weeks to have the
fundamental energy level you need to
operate in in zero and in gravity every
day about 5 or six o' for two weeks I
just wanted to lay down cuz my body was
tired and it took about a week to get my
neurovestibular system set so I could
you know I have the same problem myself
anyway all right go ahead what happens
to the garbage that you can't reuse or
recycle on the space station on the
space station actually garbage is one of
the big problems because people it's
always an afterthought right the trash I
mean think about it you just kind of
throw it in the trash bag and it goes to
the curb so what we do is uh the
progress is an un cargo vehicle that
arrives from Russia every 3 or four
months and Japan and Europe have
vehicles that show up uh once or twice a
year and we end up loading a lot of the
trash that we can't reuse onto those
vehicles and then they burn up uh as
they reenter the atmosphere so we're
using the atmosphere as a big garbage
incinerator but ideally you want to be
able to recycle as much as possible all
right young man go ahead my question is
this like if you're on Space can you
like like how do you swim like can you
like you I you told in the presentation
that you could do Sports and could you
swim or play
basketball B basketball will be tough
unless you change the game so you go
find a corner in the space station and
your hoop would be near the corner so
you have to bank the ball off the
corners to get into the hoop so that
could be kind of a new game you can make
up but you can't just shoot regularly
because once you shoot the boss is going
to take the trajectory that you you shot
it's it's not going to come down and Arc
down into the hoop you you know the
sport you should do in space is quiddit
right from Harry Potter that be the
perfect sport wouldn't it right exactly
you need little rocket propelled
broomsticks to change direction but you
could do that but I don't think swimming
would work very well either all right
young man go what was your favorite
experiment that you did in space gosh
there there were so many interesting
experiments I think one of the fun
things that we had was we were lighting
little fires to it was in the glove box
and we were hopefully little
fires
we're CU combustion changes in space too
the whole the way Fire Burns and we're
trying to understand that for all kinds
of reasons and so we finally got the
first combustion experiments in space
while we were there and we were lighting
little fires and trying to figure out
when they smoke and watching it it's
really it was really fascinating Flames
Flames are circular in space right they
don't do
this yeah that's a convection driven uh
phenomenon right go ahead young lady
what's the funnest thing you do in
Space the funnest thing hm
I think for me it was uh you know just
after our hard work and our mission
sitting down with a group of people and
having dinner and playing with our food
you know the the water bubble like
like trying to eat your food and have it
float all over the place that was pretty
much fun looking out the windows got to
count right that's F yeah you never get
tired of looking out the window you guys
really press your nose against the glass
I mean and can you use Windex to clean
it you once you press your nose against
the glass you really can't get any good
photos there it ruins it doesn't it yeah
okay young man can animals adjust to
space can what can can animals adjust to
space of course we're animals we adjust
but you know some animals do better than
others right the uh the mice seem to
fall into a couple categories there's
the way cool mice they just float along
inside their little habitat and they're
not freaking out or anything they're
just going with the flow and then
there's the the more anxious mice and
they're kind of doing this the whole
time because they haven't quite figured
out why there's nothing underneath their
paws or or what's going on so so we have
seem to have two little two levels of
mice so far that would be an interesting
study to figure out what makes a mouse
anxious or cool you know yeah we do that
we actually do that research that's yeah
yeah well that's why we fly different
animals that Human animals but that's
why you fly little animals as well see
how their developmental processes go and
the the hypothesis how will they adapt
we actually have a hypothesis about the
astronauts they adapt really well maybe
they can have dually adapt to Earth One
gravity and they can also adapt to
microgravity like you can adapt to
putting your glasses on your spectacles
well a little more complicated for a
space flight it's all you know body
motor control maybe space flight
programs to float around get back to
Earth now you have your 1G Earth
programs exactly all right young lady if
you are on a spacewalk in the space suit
and you need to scratch your nose or
your face what would you do there you go
that's a big one explain that one yeah
um that's a great question you know what
it hasn't been solved that's why we need
you you cannot scratch your nose in the
current space suit and not with our
space suit either you can this has been
a problem in the the past there have
been astronauts who have had real so you
scratched before you know it's a good
it's a good time to practice
meditation and you can move your nose
over and maybe rub it on something well
the Val Salva pad front of the right
there that you use to Val Salva you can
get your nose there but if it's like a
back in here somewhere you can have a
problem but it's funny because you
forget I I haven't done a space block
but I've trained and I've been in the
water and my nose starts itching without
even thinking about it I move my hand
it's like
qu yeah wait that work you know so this
suit is great for that yeah go ahead um
I'm kind of wearing fingerless gloves
here I don't know if you can see and
I've been reading about the BIOS suit
research and I read that you had trouble
getting the pressure suit to generate
enough pressure so I was wondering if
you could do some kind of intermediate
thing where it was like regular
astronaut gloves until the fingers and
then the fingers were made out of the
stuff that squeezes yep it's a really
it's a really good point so well you did
your homework by the way can give her a
round of applause
there that's right I mean that's why I
think of those gloves are good on Earth
because your your hands are warm but you
can move your fingers I think you have a
future student here so mechanical
counter pressure and uh in all honesty
the glove design is as complicated as
almost the whole suit because think of
how many degrees of freedom you have so
we do have gloves that are kind of
shrink crappy or mechanical counter
pressure gloves but we're still in the
research they're not ready for flight
yet still in the research level we can
get up to 20 to the the the suit we can
actually get to 30 kilopascals now so
we've we've kind of hit our design
reference with a suit the gloves were
probably still about 20 25
so how many years before this suit could
really
be out there in space what do you figure
um depends it all depends on about money
right it's all about the about the money
I have we have great students look at
this you know we have all the student we
have all the knowledge we need um we
need a little bit more time if if uh if
we really put our mind to it probably
two to three years might take us 10
we'll be ready for Mars that's for sure
all right go ahead um how does a person
become an
astronaut well you know it's remarkably
simple you call and get an application
and and put it on file we're basically
civil servants uh we do have a mix of
military and civilian astronauts so some
people choose to take the military route
there are certain requirements that you
have to meet as a minimum uh you know
technical degree or a medical degree or
it's it's probably useful to have at
least a master's but the applications
now online Craigslist right yeah maybe
you just apply and then the application
goes on file when they're ready to
select a class they make an announcement
anybody who's got an active application
on file is considered exactly um
eligible and we start you know going
through the application so the trick is
of course building up your experience to
match what what you need and here's
where you sound like where I sound a
little bit like a parent I don't want to
interject too much but you got to study
hard you got to stay in school and study
hard go ahead but what you need to do is
study what you love doing you know don't
don't study something because you think
it's going to get you to become an
astronaut you know the astronaut is a
cherry on the top we have scientists and
Engineers all throughout NASA that have
done really great and wonderful things
so I was a I was a scientist before I
became an astronaut for 10 years at Nasa
Langley and so was you know so was Sandy
she was an engineer so do what you love
doing eat your green beans listen to
your teachers and your parents no and
just have a passion for what you're
doing you know with your spirit and
opportunity you can do anything what fun
stuff do you do in space fun stuff in
space well we already talked a little
bit about that one other fun thing you
do in space Oh gosh the the top one is
just looking out the window being a
projectile having someone you know you
up in a ball and have someone just push
you like bowling with astronauts just
roll you down the down the module it's
fun to be a projectile huh all right
come here young lady come here oh I'm
sorry I apologize young man um why isn't
there air in
space Dava d d or maybe your future
student would want to answer that one I
don't know so um when you saw the
astronauts in space station in the
shuttle there's air because we put in
artificial environment there we put a
whole life support system so it's kind
of like what we have here in this room
and we package that up and put the
pressure and put the air in but it's a
great question the vacuum of space we
find out in orbit what we find on the
moon the
vacuum there's no air there so you
wouldn't be able to survive without a
space suit on we have to bring our
oxygen we have to put you in a
pressurized suit so the vacuum of space
there's not air that's why so clean
there's a vacuum up there all right so
go ahead young man what happens what
happens when you get sick in space good
question now you can you be honest about
been there been there done that we
didn't really talk about this but this
is a very common problem yeah when when
I got to orbit on my my first and second
flight I had a had a turkey sandwich and
I probably shouldn't have eaten that
turkey sandwich right when I got to
space but um did some work and I just
felt you rent rented the turkey sandwich
huh rented yeah yeah and um but we have
you know bags like you do on the ground
if if you get sick in an airplane and
you just the thing is though this stuff
just comes out and goes everywhere so
you have to make sure you capture it
close it off and put it away in the wet
trash so it's I mean it's something that
happens and people that fly in the Zerg
airplane sometimes get sick sometimes
they don't but it doesn't it's not a
good Coral are for if you'll get sick in
space because in the in the zero g plane
I did not get sick but in space I did
hey dava it as I understand it uh
correct me if I'm wrong more women than
men get sick in space is that true um
not exactly we don't have any
statistical significance um and we don't
have as many women flying so we don't
have a gender difference but the cor guy
who told me that
see no it's not true but for boat
sickness or car sickness there isn't
really isn't a Cory we do know that it's
your vision and then your vestibular
system your inner ears and it's a
conflict between those signals that
makes you pretty upset but you get over
it I mean I've sailed around the world
hey I get seasick but hey get seasick
the first night you know everyone adapts
to it and S for you I mean I assume in a
long stint eventually your body oh yeah
you pretty quickly but they tell us a
trick as a rookie and this refers to to
what you were talking about David is the
very for the first 24 hours keep
yourself in a 1G orientation so that
your eyes have sort of a normal vision
because that's how you trained right
you've been standing on the floors and
you've been going down the ladder so
don't immediately dive head first down
the ladder into the mid deck and and
start Pro keep your head up keep your
head up for a day and that helps gravity
okay go ahead hi what is the material on
the space suit and is there a purpose
for all of the red seaming great thank
you very much question love the question
so it's um since we're trying to apply a
third of an atmosphere it's actually a
passive elastic this is our fourth Tri
at it and I say MIT colors why it's
silver and
red sorry of white ones too um and so
underneath the silver part is kind of
passive elastics and the red line lines
are really key so you saw Rachel doing
some movements I want to give her
maximum Mobility but I still have to
apply this pressure how do I do that so
the design that actually the patent
behind the design the red lines are
sorry about the technical part something
called lines of non-extension just real
quickly if you put circles all over your
skin and moved they would turn
elliptical so you go from a circle to an
ellipse there'll be two bisecting
diameters that pivot and you connect the
red dots we didn't try out we we didn't
start out to be a Spider-Man suit but uh
the threedimensional mathematical
analysis leads you to this red pattern
and that's what's key to get the maximum
mobility and keep the structure if you
will it must have been very painstaking
getting that all oh no come no problem
minutes five minutes all right young
lady go ahead when you're in space do
you get
homesick good question actually you know
I I was a little homesick at Christmas I
have to admit CU my father had passed
away ear in the year and I knew it was
going to be rough on my family and but
the good thing is that that we get a
video conference with our family every
week and so I got to see my family every
week and then at Christmas I spent two
hours on a video conference with them
and that was really nice so you have a
lot of ways to keep in touch with your
family you can make phone calls or do
email you got the video conference so
you can stay connected pretty well I
think one last question well we we had
the last question okay this is it you
get it hey when you're on a space walk
how well are you Tethered to the space
station and do you have a fail safe if
you can we take okay yeah you did so
space I trained I didn't do one well
there we have some uh we have some um
they like little clips that you grab
hold onto your suit and you you
translate around and you have these
wires that run around the station so you
want to make sure that you know you're
clipped on and we have you know
procedures that we follow routinely to
make sure that you're Tethered to these
to these um these guy wires but if you
do come undone we do have a a device
that you can pull out some little hand
controllers and it shoots nitrogen out
of the back and you can point yourself
in the right direction you get like what
10 15 seconds of of burst and hopefully
you're pointed in the right way so it's
like a little J like a jet pack it's a
little jet little Jetson's jetpack yeah
yeah but it's kind of it's it's no
different than really mountain climbing
you just want to make sure you're always
strapped in somehow all right we're
we're out of time for questions I know
there's a ton more but these two
characters are going to be in the NASA
booth in ghoul Plaza right out here as
of 3 p.m. today right and uh they will
they they will answer your questions
till how long till they'll be there for
days they'll be different days yeah so
uh feel free to go and get your
questions and now we have one special
treat here now we don't have enough for
everybody but our six students stand up
once again give them a round of applause
for their wonderful questions would you
like the answers are good come on up on
the stage we want to tell about a little
surprise for them uh we brought some
well I didn't bring it well yeah you did
you brought it astronaut food they're
going to be our astronaut food Samplers
we going to give you a an
unbiased uh critique of the astronaut
food right you're just going to tell us
what it's all about have a little sample
what do we what do we have in here
Leland uh I think we have some chocolate
pudding cake there's
one and we have apricot
cobbler this is tell them to hold it
straight up hold it straight up it's cut
on the side this way other way this way
yeah so you're going to scoop it down we
have that messy gravity here gravity
messing us up okay we have vanilla
pudding and these are going to be our
taste
testers another vanilla
pudding so these are some of our our
favorite desserts I mean some of our
favorite desserts and as I mentioned we
were on a we're on a 16 day rotating
menu and so you do get quite a lot of
variety although the textures are all
the same I think you guys can dig in go
ahead and start eating don't don't be
bash be careful don't be bash um what
you end up missing a lot is crispy and
fresh so so for example I wanted lettuce
um and something that was crunchy when I
got back and uh there's some food that
tastes very good uh like these desserts
I think are pretty good and cream
spinach is good and and some of the
Russian vegetable dishes are very good
some food is very bad the meatloaf is
not so good and what's that uh that
pickled herring that the Russians have
or what is it they have a fish thing
that yeah I think um what the first US
astronaut to fly to the space station
mirror
his food didn't show up on time his name
was norm thard and Norm thard you meet
him today he's probably 130 lbs dripping
wet he lost 30 lbs I mean he it was a
serious weight loss because he couldn't
stand the the the fish and all the other
things it wasn't it's just not what
you're used to it's a different diet and
it really is a matter getting used to it
we do taste testing in Russia now so we
we can I think they learned a lesson off
of that one because they have you know a
lot of the cans that come up are Russian
food in their their it's heavy meats and
stews which is great but you can't eat
that all the time all right let's get an
assessment here how is the chocolate
pudding okay thumbs up with it's thumbs
up and it's very very chocolatey very
all right what do you got you got
chocolate pit cake too what do you think
be
honest what good good thumbs up all
right you have vanilla pudding how is it
different oh okay is it thumbs up or
thumbs down MOS I think huh
[Music]
yeah appreciate her cander do you know
what I did on orbit I added this re
hydrated strawberries to that it made it
a lot better now see that's it that was
good you learned the tri you had you
have vanilla pudding too what do you
what do you think I thought it was
pretty good pretty good thumbs up or
thumb scale of 1 to 10 what would you
say seven seven seven okay seven okay
and you are a apricot cobbler how is it
it tastes better than it
looks and actually that's kind like your
meal that you made right all SPAC tast
it's not not a visual thing is it no
and what what is your assessment of the
apricot cobbler tastes it tastes great
like it tastes really good do you like
it one of my favorites too all right the
people in the kitchen at Johnson Space
Center will be glad to hear all this
because they work very hard on all this
all right well listen you guys are great
you all were great Dave everybody Rachel
Sandy L all of you great great session
thank you for coming enjoy the rest of
the festival go out in the square and
and see the booths and ask them some
questions have a good
day